hello everybody my name is mark hi
player and welcome to plug and play the
reason i'm enunciating is because i've
been jumbling my words too much today
and i'm gonna actually play a game
that's been recommended by you guys
to some great extent and people have not
been very secretive that this game is
strange
missed my target there we go welcome to
plug and play
it's an indie game that was released on
steam just a little bit ago uh that's
supposed to be an
artistic title and i don't know a lot
about it
but from the trailer and from what i've
seen and what people have said
this game is apparently very bizarre i
did not know it's gonna get bizarre
right away
okay so we got fingers oh i can move
them
oh this is normal oh this is completely
natural
no ah bad touch i don't want to play
hey die bob oh oh oh it's like that
is it you're just gonna run away after i
dive bomb you
are we going for a second try here
it's awfully dramatic music for what's
going on
you go up you go down and then you'll
never
ever touch no stay away stay away
stranger danger
well this is bizarre okay bye then
should i just let him touch
i guess i should just let him touch can
i can i force him along their route
all right go for it go for you crazy
kids
you touch away i ain't gonna judge
oh oh no touch touch touch oh you didn't
like that
i don't know what i'm doing i don't know
if i'm doing this right or not
what the hell is supposed to be
happening touch
touch the thing touch the other finger
you gonna touch it you don't touch it
i'm gonna touch her i'm gonna touch it
so good
what my freaking fingernail disappeared
now the running
plugman
oh
okay bye have a good day at school oh
hey again
hi are you looking at me
okay all right then
oh hey
now you're doing something oh that's so
cool
there's so much for me to commentate on
in this game how about you go
say hi to the guy say hi to the guy say
hi to the guy
okay bye he didn't say hi to the guy
oh no oh i should totally put that back
in because i was enjoying this so far
ah i missed wha oh man i must be drunk
oh nope not drunk
oh now it's reverse
hey that's not weird at all hello
are you my friend befriend
oh be friend oh be such friend
oh we're all friends wait
well you could
oh okay i think i'm understanding it
whoa okay
i don't understand it at all i was about
to reach enlightenment and you just
pulled it all away from me i'm gonna
pull out your plugs
i'm gonna pull out your plugs wait okay
so oh they can't go apart okay they must
go
closer together they must
they must and apparently we're in a
forest where there's crickets and
whatnot
oh okay yeah all right i'm starting to
see the picture
well all right then you dick bag
what an a-hole oh come on
oh you dingus dary at least they're
lining up all head to crotch like that
that's awfully convenient
poop again
what am i supposed to do with this hey
well i feel like a kindergartner
who was held back a few times because i
can't understand this
well i don't want it i don't want it
i don't want it how about you leave me
alone
oh
okay i still don't get it but i did it
what what why'd you turn into a pig nose
head
what are you getting ready for why do i
need to click on your bum bum
oh
come on are you serious here are you
serious
are you really serious
well i'm glad that we went through this
adventure together
you pooped out your pins isn't that cool
bonk you want it you want it i guess not
why why dude
a boop ya a boopy in your big piggy nose
nose
so what am i supposed to do am i
supposed to shove these back in is that
what i'm supposed to do
go fetch go fetch
oh i see that is what i was supposed to
do hey
you follow the leader follow the leader
go get him buddy go get him this makes
total sense
i'm having so much fun
yes and
well done sir well done you did good
you did real good okay so take this out
of there
put that in there then we got a button
all right we got a button all right take
this out of there
put that in there put this in there we
got two buttons
oh good buttons good buttons what are
you gonna do
you're gonna do what i think you're
gonna do you better get to it
hello hello goodbye oh hello hey hello
hello hi
do you know me i know you you know me
i don't know you i know
you do i do
you do do you no
yes no yes
no yes yes no
glad we reached an agreement that
talking was phenomenal
i'm so happy hello do you want to be my
friend oh
do you love me do you love me i don't
know
i think you love me i don't love you
enough
enough what is not enough neither do i
do you want to hug me
i'm not here no and i'm not sure you
love me
i love you i don't think i love you
are you sure i think you don't love me
hug me i'm not sure
do you listen to me i do
surely not yes no
yes yes no
great oh i'm
so enamored with the emotions
and i should be drunk
i love you i don't think i love you
i love you i think you don't love me
i know i love you i'm not sure
i do love you i don't
why does it hurt
i'm leaving okay bye thank you
i guess i don't think i'm doing this oh
he's sad now he tilted his head slightly
and that means he's sad now
okay click bamboozled
bibble boozled whoa all right then well
i guess we're back here now can i pull
these things out of your head
probably hey blurbly barbie i'm a bunch
of oh
wait wait wait oh oh it's just a center
moment
oh oh i unplugged them oh
are you getting some ideas there oh
okay
great
i guess this is a metaphor for a
threesome bloop bloop not for the
kitties
oop oh it almost got there
okay almost almost almost head
right up his bum bum ah this is so weird
why is this even a thing go yes walk
walk walk my human centipede walk
oh no no no no done okay
you will become one of us one of us
one of us whatever
well then i'm glad this all went exactly
to plan
jiggle jiggle jiggle jiggle jiggle
jiggle jiggle jiggle
jiggle jiggle yay
all right all right all right
all right damn it damn you
yeah you got to meet in the middle you
got to meet in the middle that's the
lesson
i don't even know how this is gonna work
but okay
you're gonna be in the middle you gotta
put one prong
in you put one prong out
you put one prong in
and then you shake it all about well all
righty then
is this supposed to have a meeting
this supposed to mean any girl god
oh oh oh
oh boy this is a fun
game i'm so happy about this
game oh great
great okay let's cross the streams
now we do this do daddy dookie cool
the fingers again i was wondering
oh their whole hands don't miss don't
don't miss i can't control you
what are you doing you missed okay
what game are we playing here what are
you trying to get out of here
what are we doing is this game of pull
my finger is that like that's
explosive animation where i gotta push
your finger and then create a black hole
inside your butthole where people are
gonna plug into apparently
yeah i got your nose or finger whatever
same thing i don't know anatomy
my name is mr hand i'm not the same guy
from the
internet i am different
very different oh yeah me too
i don't like tiny bucks too but don't
mind me i'm not even close to related to
him
well i should go now oh
no what
click caboose it's just okay
no you're making okay bye then you're
making it uneven
uneven is bad i didn't know that door
was there great
whoa hi all right this is logical i like
the way you're thinking here
oop right in there i
nothing strange about the way that looks
oh no he's gone limp yeah there's
nothing at all strange about with the
way this looks
oh
that's the end it says end up in there
what's that what the hell boy we got a
limped finger going on here
ah
all right i guess that's the end of it
so there you go
that's plug and play the ladder the
moral of the story
is
i don't know why i wasted your time or
why you stuck with this so
hey hey prizes for everybody
i just beamed my kid in the back of the
head with a gallon of milk
perfectly normal dad stuff no
oh i know you don't
get back here it sticks to my body
thank you for sticking around to the end
of the video but unfortunately you found
a homework assignment
i want you to write the most descriptive
description
of what the hell happened in this damn
game
because i don't know and i bet you don't
know either
but i want to hear your reasoning anyway
please be as detailed as possible
and use as many innuendos as you would
desire
so thanks again everybody so much for
being here
you're beautiful plug and play
life's hard shouldn't you be too
booperduper